foreign
[Music]
just some self-reflection okay just a
little confession and self-reflection
confession kind of confession
self-reflection just whatever just
listen all right sharpen is it fam so
yeah
I realized so obviously for everyone
listening and uh watching who had and I
have just driven back from Manchester
all the way back down to London it took
four hours it did
and turns out I can't be trusted in the
car by myself
for four hours what did you do farm it
it got tyrannical in there I was doing
the most and Okay cool so basically I
went full split personality okay
full full split personality and like
dependent on the tune was playing
different roles who had
okay I've got I think I've got like four
different roles that I fully played and
invested in okay round number one yeah
um the song was Drake
um no friends in the industry okay and I
was a civilian minding my business and I
got approached by a Ruffian
um
a man put pause up put pause on my chest
and I was like swear
and I broke into a crab battle
well I could I took it West Coast
straight to him
found no friends in the industry
and I was ah
and I hit him with the like the the Rope
yeah yeah
and then he he wasn't ready for it he
wasn't ready for Imaginary this was Ill
in my head but no it's not in my head
because while I'm driving I'm doing it
yeah yeah yeah yeah
The Clash was fully imaginary yeah yeah
and he wanted to fight but then he
realized like wow
and I was I was on him
fine I was on him yeah and he just
didn't want the smoke yeah and then that
was wrong number one okay Wrong five
minutes I had to pull the record up okay
I had to pull the Trap up okay to finish
like my battles
seconds
[Laughter]
roll yeah
I was fam second raw I was in cheeks
yes second round was in cheeks the song
was
um
uh candy drip by
candy Drip by Flippin uh what's his
flipping name bro
um
um I know you're talking about um the
album's called candy drip the guy that
um um interview yeah huh Lucky Day lucky
day thank you sir candy Drip by lucky
day yeah fam I was in cheeks yeah I was
in cheeks and when the song's playing
yeah when I'm saying I'm in it yeah and
I'm talking in my car and I'm saying
take it take it take it take it I don't
play in both roles like no Daddy it's
too big take it take it bro I was there
take it it's a psychosis sharp that's
what I'm saying shop take it and my
voice is cracking shut up shut up and
take it I'm thinking raw people are just
driving that's what I'm thinking this is
exactly what I'm thinking and then yeah
it kind of just got based on it as well
yeah yeah I don't think you'd take it
take it Matt Ross roll number two yeah
roll number three yeah was
um what was the song it was uh roll
number three what song was it bro so it
was
um it might have been some Wizkid song
or something like that I can't actually
remember what the third song was but bro
my my waist was moving yeah in his own
realm and dementia okay and I thought
just allow me everyone's done this I
don't care if they have it I was
thinking bro if I was actually a chick
yeah I reckon I could hold a wine on a
guy okay so then I played both roles
yeah so I'm dead like ah if I'm like ah
I don't know I'm also the guy like wrong
ah
sat on him Sat on it in the shoes
I don't go it ended up the steering was
here and um looking back yeah and I'm
also the guy like and then now the
cereal was here and I'm like and then I
I made imaginary eye contact with the DJ
who was like wrong yeah Ryan sector four
yeah don't need that and I'm just saying
that say let's say let's say let's say
she's doing the most and I'm there ah
bro yeah that was row number three roll
number four the final form yeah
was an actual battle okay this was me
Angie okay it was me Andrew because I
imagined because obviously on the way up
you drove past me yeah and I remember
thinking what is going to drive past me
again I was thinking about that on the
way down too fast and um and the song
was your thing the uh bus stop thing
and then you were like bro I think it is
and I just came in like I came in hot
weather it wasn't even yeah it wasn't
even like yeah yeah reciprocation but
they knew what it was and all of a
sudden there's a light and I come in
like hot but I'm walking I'm walking
forward slowly so imagine my head's like
this
Sweden yeah yeah yeah so I've come in
yeah yeah yeah as a number pushing these
sons and they're like like me and my
girl
yeah
fam and I came in hard yeah yeah yeah
and then I'm there and I'm doing the
most yeah and I'm also in the crowd like
rise double jointed okay
jointed
I'm dead during the months
okay take it home yeah yeah yeah yeah
take it home well it was mad he's like
yeah he's double changed
and then I'm opening and then like you
open the Gateway
That's What You Got Served yeah and
they're like wrong yeah I really really
did it that does happen to me quite a
bit to be fair like obviously I drive
alone by myself a lot of the time yeah
it's one of those ones where obviously
it depends on the song but um it
happened to me when I was listening to
um is it no BS
um
is there no BS that goes um where it
seem Young Money CNB using just the BNB
then the D and D that one
I think it might be a you know me like
on pnd so that when that I was listening
to that um I think it's on the way down
here and when that part comes these two
parts of that song
or just Milly rocking face was mean
mugging my face was mean that was me
with your first role yeah
I was there fast bro
the wine thing
whatever I said
bro sat on it sounded I was like wow if
I was a chick I would actually shop lap
stuff I'll shut laps down in the dance
oh it's hilarious bro hilarious yeah
but I was thinking every person that
drove past my freaking ball what's going
on in that car yeah what's going on in
there there's a party no I was having
the time I needed it to make it through
that drive I needed that you need a
distraction oh fam it was like a solid a
good 45 minutes of just that in my world
yeah in my world was it at the beginning
of the journey or that towards the end
perfect mid okay because the beginning
was rough oh yeah you've been angry fam
the beginning was rough I didn't think I
was going to make it then I had a
monster and then that monster kicked in
and then I was listening to a podcast
because that's what I usually like to
listen to but then something was telling
me music music and there's a dart fan
there's a dawn on
Tick Tock because I can't remember his
name otherwise I would actually give him
a shout out some American Don
and all he does is um
music recommendations okay
wow okay wow it's been dropping some
bangers okay if I find out I'll send you
he's got a whole thing
um and he's been throwing bangers and
he's my taste okay he puts in there and
a lot of the songs I know already but
they're just songs I forgot about and
other songs like one of the ones that he
uh put in there was um songs for women
by Frank Ocean I haven't heard that song
in years and when I heard I was like oh
straight to Spotify okay straight on the
like list okay yeah this guy's hot his
recommendations are hot say less I mean
if you find it shot me or something all
right but yeah that's my um that's my
[__] that's hilarious
um so guys we're gonna go straight into
the
um weekly question and the question of
the week this week was what's the
wildest thing you've ever heard in a
random conversation oh yummy yeah yummy
yes I'm just gonna I'm just gonna spill
them off as I actually do
I overheard my mum say to my dad I like
the way he performed last night
yeah you're making me so sick fam I like
the way you performed oh maybe so yeah I
can't hear I can't hear stuff like that
have some self-respect
that a woman cured her friend's cancer
with crystals
their tongue was bleeding the bite down
on that tongue was bleeding I couldn't
hear that yeah facts I couldn't hear
that how do you shave your booty hole
your booty hair sorry
that's disgusting how do you shave your
booty here
two girls talking on one said whilst I
was sat on my on his face I farted
bro
there's been a a change in the
atmosphere and there's been a lot of
female fart talk recently there has been
there's been a lot of female Fighters
recently they're just letting it fly
yeah they are I mean do what you do you
need to do promise you you're not
sitting on my face invited promise you
that's not a thing that happens you
aren't in control of it facts you are in
control and we're having a time and you
can sit on my face yeah
um you actually don't have a choice yeah
if you need to fight yeah because I'm
doing the most
strapped in bro I'm parallel parking
yeah do you know what I mean I'm
strapped in yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
I'm not gonna smell it because I
suffocated yeah I'm not gonna smell it
regardless regardless to do what you
need to do I'm locked in but yeah that's
wild yeah and what's the weirdest thing
you've ever heard in a random convo one
of the neighbors yelling stop clenching
stop clenching just out of context stop
clenching could be fist it could be
Tommy could be it could be anything it
could stop any clenching yeah bro I
remember
um
the first time this is so Random yeah
the first one of the uh uh
one time when I was dating a girl uh in
uni and we didn't bang for ages okay
this the this is the girl yeah yeah
um the crazy one yeah
um we didn't buy for ages and she was
doing some dry hunting for time yeah and
when she was on top yeah as like she'd
move forward she was clenching it was
the most disgusting thing to this day
that I can ever fathom but it was
clenching when she moved forward I was
like every time I would feel it Rockstar
jumps on her cheeks and then they would
just relax in my hands
they would relax into my Palms it was
yucky food it was grinding she was
grinding the cheeks sort of squeezing
time my day she wanted to feel it all
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
thanks let's say less
she gets her head game from her mum
that's for damn sure what
what who said this that's for damn sure
wow yeah wow
wow she Drew her eyebrows like she's got
Parkinson's
that's disgraceful heard a guy chatting
up a gun in the club say you bring up my
girlfriend way too much
[Laughter]
you bring up my girl way too much I'm
trying to chops bro shut up
[__]
[__] yeah so you know who she is
she is
shut up
God
[Laughter]
hilarious walking past the couple in the
train oh so walking past a couple in the
train station and overheard him say to
her that's why your dad left you
no one's ever said that
to a real man and woman conversation
that's why your dad left you
some people have no we've said it before
no fear of consequence none there's zero
fear of consequence no that's why your
dad left you you can't say that because
I confided in you yeah you can't throw
that back at me because I can find it in
you yeah stuff like that because it's
just not cool man
a girl in my high school casually
mentioned she [__] the dad that the
kids who babysits the dads of the
kitchen babysits yeah but I thought that
immediately Then I then I heard High
School oh yeah so that's like 16 Max
oh well not in America they graduate 18
18. they're still
still wow okay do you know what I mean
yeah it's yeah that's a bit dad's plural
what's wrong with these man they can't
yeah yeah it's mad that's wild uh a lady
said when she did anal with her man it
hit her tailbone and now she has lower
back pain
wow that's just messing with the nose
it's just messing with the nurse that's
lower back okay
from anal
bruh stop
I would I couldn't forgive myself
if I was the guy I would think gang
obviously
but for a little for one luck yeah it's
got chronic back pain yeah that's yeah
that's wheelchair yeah yeah yeah that's
literally wow that's literally
wheelchair stuff wow wow
my boyfriend doesn't understand I needed
the money that's why I ended up having
sex with both of them this is something
someone overheard yeah my boyfriend
doesn't understand I needed the money
wow that's a Dubai thing factual that's
a Dubai sexual I'm not ready to lose you
I'll even hire a BBC just to keep you
satisfied
mad so there I was whipped cream on my
tease and then he came back in with
sausages
mom was not in it
he took everything from the fridge came
back with sausages Barrel was whipped
cream on my titties
I got a couple more I haven't I haven't
done a whipped cream thing since I was a
kid I don't think I've ever done a
whipped cream it's pointless yeah ever I
don't think ever and it's actually it's
splits
someone say once you mix a life of
whipped cream it starts to split and you
get little whipped creamy blotches and
it's never just a clean list yeah and I
don't really and it turns out I didn't
realize in this until I was in the
moment I don't really [__] with whipped
cream that much okay and then I remember
I did it on I did it nipples and Tom and
then once I got it off the Tom that was
Bear whipped cream stuff all around no I
remember thinking yeah usually got dairy
in your [__]
you've got dairy in there I don't think
that's sanitary I remember I was like
17. I was thinking this is yeah yeah
someone needs to put a rule book on time
because we shouldn't be smudging dairy
in there and I'm I'm about to bang yeah
yeah it's just gonna go it's going all
the way up oh my God this shouldn't be
dairy in there you know all right last
thing last two rubber what's the wildest
thing you've ever heard in a random
conversation
do you ever just look at a cliff and
just want to jump off wow
do you ever just look at a clip wanna
jump off
nah brother I promise you you couldn't
say that to me because I I was thinking
tread softly yes because I want to react
I'd wonder what you want to say I'd want
to be like brother yeah I don't think
you realize how I have how badly I've
not thought that yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I don't think you're deep in how
crazy that is
and then you tell me that and I'll just
you'll just see the does a lot
you hear that it was a lock and when you
look at the door I say calm calm down
calm down oh man thinks I'm trying to
commit siren yeah yeah you don't know
about it yet but you're trying to do
something
last one I just caught my boyfriend
having another threesome last night
another
and there's some stuff that I don't
understand how women live through
brother another Point what do you mean
another another threesome first of all
gang for this guy just patting him
threesomes
first of all wow how where how why
second of all what do you mean you got
caught doing it twice brother no respect
zero respect obviously not the same two
things yeah yeah oh yeah he's just doing
up multiple threesomes that's crazy he
doesn't care he really doesn't care
about him he really doesn't care about
wow wow that was a question of the week
that was a that was a nice quick one
yeah
um but yeah welcome guys yeah welcome
back to the second best podcast on
planet Earth soon to be the first soon
to be the first when Joe Rogan kicks the
bucket yep so um guys if you do enjoy
the podcast please please please please
please head on over to patreon.com
forward slash shits and gigs and you can
binge over three years worth of content
you can catch a bonus episode of ours
every single Thursday as well as joining
our massive cult baby community over on
our Discord so heading on over there
today it's going to cost you a very very
light three pound a month something for
your day you need to run the pizza sng
and join the cult for good for good
um guys if you are watching us on
YouTube mission 1 million is still very
much a thing so please subscribe to the
Channel please keep the notification
Bell on so you know when we're posting
we're trying to do numbers facts trying
to get paid facts so do us a favor also
guys if you are um
if you are on any podcast app please
drop us a follow or subscribe and please
please please leave a nice review for us
means the world
does a lot for the show five stars is
preferable
fam turns out so there's this thing I
don't even remember signing up to it but
there's a thing I can't remember what
it's called but I basically get an email
like once a week and it was like oh
these are all the people that have left
reviews on your show oh sick it's not
sick oh because
turns out first of all I'm done reading
comments I barely barely do anyway but
I'm actually over it okay because
someone was talking about this on
another podcast I listened to the other
day and they were talking about how like
it's actually impossible the way the
human mind is set up the human mind is
set up to detect threats
okay that's just literally how it is so
you can have
threats if I'm detect threats okay
um so you can have 9 000 positive
comments right yeah and then one
negative one and your brain has to focus
on that negative one because it's a
threat why are you talking [__] so
um it's actually impossible to just like
first of all it's also not normal to be
reading such nice things about yourself
all the time because it's just not
healthy
um and then secondly yeah you you take
in that bad comment every single time so
I really really
um I sometimes skim through the reviews
and when they caught me the other day
someone put a one star on there and was
like saw these guys and Tick Tock well
they'll be funny turns out they're
misogynistic Pricks all right like do
not recommend listening to this one star
and I was like
well that's my evening
that turns out that's my evening ruined
that's hilarious I couldn't think
couldn't stop thinking about it yeah for
about four hours my blood rang cold and
I was like wow I'm never reading one of
these again this is not fair yeah it's
just my day Reuben from a stranger
couldn't couldn't run
um but yeah guys make sure you leave
them leave the reviews I just won't read
them it turns out I'm just not going to
read them yeah when I saw that one star
I was like swear I said that
misogynistic pricks I was like I'll just
go pack it in then wow how about that
strange person they use a four six nine
seven turns out I'll just pack it in
Alias yeah yeah file stuff file of our
stuff so
um
Last of Us is now finished oh yeah so
Last of Us finale was last would have
been last Monday
um and it was I was saying to Ellis
before you got here
um as a whole series obviously it's
fantastic
um but I was disappointed with the
finale because if you take away the
adverts it was probably like 45 minutes
long yeah everyone's complaining about
that I didn't know I didn't really mind
I minded I wanted more I wanted
something it's the end I know but is it
because I was asking Alice if there's
going to be a season two there's going
to be season two yeah correct everything
wrong with this but um obviously season
one's based on the first game season two
is based on the second game
um have you played the second game yeah
it's got a lot of controversy though
yeah fam my brother said it's
controversial the second game the second
game's controversial what sense so it
doesn't it isn't for the same characters
right or it does
uh yeah I'm not obviously I'm not gonna
spoil it because they might carry it on
but uh yeah
um there's an additional character and
it follows them for most of the game and
it's like really controversial Yeah so
basically what my brother told me is it
follows this new character
um and then it follows uh basically the
whole game is based on two different
points of perspective okay
um and you are basically groomed into
believing that this one person is a
villain throughout the whole game based
on the one perspective and then they
whole game starts again and then you see
it from another perspective and they
force you to kind of empathize with this
villain okay and see him from more of a
different perspective okay and
apparently the wider Community will
basically like there's no way you can
trip me into thinking what this guy's
done is okay okay so [__] you I'm like
[__] this so my brother was saying when
season two drops it's gonna be juicy if
they stick to the script yeah yeah but
they didn't yeah yeah season one it was
like it's gonna be crazy okay I'm it
sounds Tanta okay it sounds tanter when
you tell him I was like oh yeah yeah I
love stuff like that yeah because we can
get into good combo but we can say less
we can get into but no I didn't I tell
you I didn't mind that it was short was
because
um
some of the episodes were really long
yeah some of them were way longer than
others yeah
um so like only maybe three yeah first
episode maybe the second and the third
that was it first episode was long first
was like maybe I'm 45. yeah first
episode was like a feature though
um so yeah I I really wasn't
uh as soon as yeah as soon as they did
the first one being bear long I remember
thinking there's no way every episode
can be this long yeah yeah and then
other episodes were shorter and I think
the third one or something was like
there was yeah
I liked that because in my head it was
just like this is just organic it's just
done when it's done and they're not
trying to set some like specific time
frame for every single episode so I was
ready for potentially one episode to be
shorter than that than quite a bit but I
[__] liked it I mean I didn't dislike
it I just wasn't happy with the the
length of the episode no fair enough
don't get me wrong like it was a good
episode obviously
um Joel saying to Ellie that oh he um
whatever the the thing didn't work out
of he he duppyed he said I don't have
time for this he literally said I don't
have time for this literally said I'm
not losing two I don't have time for
this and he waits again give it back
give her back literally right now she
said where is he and he said she was
like he said I literally don't have time
for this and he was spraying bodies he
took everyone out he's a warrior yeah
that I think because they um when you
when you go back to the episode where he
found his brother and he said oh look at
what we did in the past blah blah that's
why the brothers misses didn't like him
yeah yeah we didn't actually get to see
how arms he really was same with episode
one when Donny was had Tess up and was
like how are we gonna sort this out
because as soon as John sees your eye
it's long episode two episode two yeah
yeah he was like bro it's long for
everyone
guys oh God and he will kill me
yeah when he said I don't have time for
this yeah I was like wow
yeah he he lost it a little bit he did
he he needed his daughter back
and they're walking and he's just like
yeah your love you would have loved my
daughter because of this and that that
was and then Eddie was just not on there
yeah she wasn't she knows something she
knows something and yeah man said that's
that's my you and you're not taking her
[__] your cure facts I need her facts
[__] your cure I need her she just
drapes her off and said get her off the
table a man grab the scalpel saying I'm
not gonna let you take her back bang
boring yep you're chatting [__] I need
my use tell the ladies to turn around if
you don't want this smoke turn around
yeah facts bro I would do the same yeah
yeah um but I mean Ellis you do you know
if it picks up from what he left off
it's a completely different thing on
next on the game too
right right left off it picks up okay
because obviously
he lied to her I did so fam that was
intense it was intense because she knows
he's lying why would she ask that she
knows he's lying
it really happened in the hospital what
really happened is everything you told
me true he said yeah it's facts it's
true Raiders came in Raiders came in
people injured yeah yeah
you're you're Marlene whatever gone gone
I just took her I left without a scratch
somehow carrying you
doesn't make any sense it doesn't make
sense but stop asking me questions
because I'm this is who I am I'm a
Survivor you know this you've been with
me so yeah but I won million percent
yeah yeah I would I would have lied for
my teeth right you don't know what I've
been through without the cold on the
table I've been dealing with this [__]
for 20 years since I lost my daughter
now I've got you I promise you I'm not
losing you so late I'll lie until I need
to I'll lie as long as I need to lie
facts there's no one can tell me I don't
care what you say you'll get over it
yeah you're my daughter yeah you're my
daughter I love you [__] I [__] love
you get over it literally get off I
saved your [__] life more than once
yeah more than once sharp shut up yeah
Jesus very very very good show man
um I wish it was longer but it was a
very very good show can't really I can't
really throw it because I loved how they
did a throwback about how Ellie was born
I love how they did the Ellie origin
story I love how they brought Marlene
into
um that Ellie um the Ellie's mom's
episode as well because obviously she
was the first one to see her yeah
there's so much that was tied in it was
it was really really good yeah it was
really really good it was interesting
you know and it was also like I wonder
why Marlene had such little
um screen time no not screen time like
such little to do with Ellie's life
okay because like um obviously Marlene
obviously was the one who took her from
her mom but then she must have just
dropped her off somewhere to the Donnies
yeah and then didn't see her again until
she was she was growing teenagers
because she she's the one who recruited
her home God as well so like this whole
time she's not even seen Ellie yeah
that's mad to me yeah yeah true true
very true but yeah you've got a question
for me anyway um yeah my question to you
was or is if you and I both woke up in
The Last of Us Universe not necessarily
the same Journey that Joel and Ellie
took but if you just woke up in that
Universe do you think we'd survive
thought
um
do I think with survive
yes but I would be
I'm gonna put my hands up I'll be accusy
[__]
I'll be humble in the qz send me my role
okay I'm on super duty yeah as long as
you're saying less okay say less you'll
see me in an apron just dashing bodies
on that fire okay yeah fam I'm I'm not
on it okay okay I'm not on it the
fireflies will get aired from me okay
okay yeah the Molly could never hit me
up and be like bro you seem like you've
got a good heart it's a firefighting a
block okay so what do you man do and as
soon as she says we liberate [__] yeah
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
I've seen these man kill people they
don't think twice yeah I'm gonna do as
I'm told I'll be an informant as well
I'll be [__] informant as well I want
all the medicine and all the best yards
yeah yeah I'll rat on everyone say less
how yeah Do You Think You'd Survive and
yeah what role would you play
um because I'm not gonna lie to you I
don't think you're a gun man I don't
think you're really on it like that
I don't the thing is I
I feel like my fight and flight is
better than I think it is okay do you
know what I mean yeah yeah and I think
it's that's why I asked do you think if
we would survive because if if you're
saying you're gonna be just following
orders I don't know if I'll survive that
way do you know what I mean because
my follow-up question was going to be if
our group chat our main group chat also
if I all woke up into this universe do
you think we'd we'd survive and not like
um try and help every single soul we see
and blah blah blah but um I'm also doing
what the man them are doing
I'm also doing what Amanda are doing if
I woke up there
and
I was on my Js yeah I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be saying yes sir yes ma'am yes
sir yeah yes sir no sir jump how high
sir yeah I don't have time for all of
this yeah yeah yeah I really don't have
time
um but yeah if demand them are all
dropping in I'm not gonna be the [__]
that's like I think we should just do as
we're told
the thing is I feel like I'll be on
stuff at the beginning okay but two
years in yeah it's just I just had a
good night's sleep yeah because this is
endless yeah it's literally endless yeah
yeah and then this whole venturing out
to Salt Lake City and all this [__] and
then like there's infected here infected
there I think I'll be on it for like a
good few months to a year and then I'd
give up yeah
nothing
I would give up bro I'll be so late
we'll be roaming through one like
deserted City and when I hear that like
I promise you I'm tapping yeah yeah send
me straight back to Boston cues same old
bang on the door
help test me as well
did you [__] touch me let me in
I'm not on it
that is yeah yeah that's Congolese chat
oh sorry sorry
I got a second of it
audience my question to you guys is
comment below
um do you think your group chat when I
say group chat you know the group chat
I'm talking about
um do you think your group chat would
survive if you woke up in The Last of Us
Universe uh comment below yeah if you
know what Rosie man are going to play
and how long are you gonna survive
comment below fam I would be in such I'm
realizing now I'll be in such a like I'm
pretty sure there would be a civil war
between I think there would be literally
another
um baby Platinum situation between you
and Jay
I'm pretty sure after a few months in
the um yeah the streets of money yeah
yeah yeah I'm pretty sure it would be
exactly like that okay because he will
just be on staff yeah and you would just
be really not honest up after a while
yeah yeah and you I think they'll get to
a point where you put your foot down on
right I'm just not doing this anymore
I'm knackered yeah yeah I just want to
do as I'm told yeah I just want to eat
some food until and he's like wow is
that what you're on swear and I'll be
somewhere in the middle you'll be on the
floor yeah yeah like I don't want to
seem like a [__] I am also knackered
yeah yeah do you know what I mean I'm
exhausted I'm [__] shattered like I'm
not gonna lie for this man sounds come
Toby's already gone it's gone no tobes
is going to be working that radio three
shifts a day
we just can't see Toby and we'll find
him a year later in Joel's brother's
situation yeah yeah yeah just youths
family settles you down yards settled
down
he's like I told you I told you I'm not
on that stuff I think they wake me up at
night and said only me can go I had no
choice they said radio wasn't allowed
yeah and so I just I just did what I
just did what I did what I did was best
really doesn't play stuff he really
really only cares about himself the toes
would be God
yeah yeah [__] hilarious yeah oh I'm
[__] that was funny guys is crotch
discomfort hurt in your game
fear no more the kings of crotch Comfort
manscaped have spent two years designing
the most comfortable boxer briefs out
there we've tried them
and we can co-sign we can vouch they're
Sleek soft comfortable and flexible the
brand new box is 2.0 from musket take
your balls to the Royal bull throne
bro what the royal ball Throne this even
makes sense that's not comfortable they
are they just that doesn't even make
sense the global leaders are below the
waist group and have the lawnmower 4.0
for the trimming so you can wear the box
as 2.0 for the chilling
we're coming with bars today yeah they
are they even trademarked the jewel
pouch so you know it's serious I think
it's time you invest in your family
jewels so that the Bulge breathe and get
20 off plus free shipping by using our
code sng Sierra November goal at
manscapes.com thank you let's get back
to the episode
um but yeah is it a question for me
you've got something for me
um some kind of uh recommendation oh
yeah I watched the whale the other day
family and needs what he got a [__]
Oscars first he did Brendan Fraser
Brendan Fraser one best actor that's mad
for me Oscar to win that's the mummy you
know yeah you want an Oscar bro a Nooks
on the moon Ah that's mad to me yeah
don't spoil it cause I'm going to watch
it I'm not gonna spoil it it follows a
basically it follows the story of uh um
well [__] played man well [__]
played because I remember seeing his
first
real acting when I was watching the
affair do you remember I didn't I forgot
he was in there he was on he's like a
dodgy prison guard or something I don't
remember I saw the effects of years ago
he's he's in that season three or four
or something
I know I didn't finish it he's good no I
didn't finish always good in it okay
always good in it okay yeah it's not to
know George of the Jungle thing anymore
he's on stuff he's good in it okay so I
remember watching that damn is that what
Brandon phrase is on
um and yes I watched it well it follows
this morbidly obese
um gay guy okay
who basically has like a week to live
okay she's [__] fat okay is he is he
the brother is he yeah the [__] guy
yeah
and he basically spends the um
he spends the movie the movie is shot
over call of course of like three days
um his last like three days where him
he's trying to reconnect with his
daughter he's got like a 17 year old
daughter trying to reconnect with her
and the whole story unfolds as that's
happening it unfolds as to
why he's so fat why he's not with his
daughter why um just a whole heap of
things you just get the whole backstory
through these last three days of his
life wow you're watching the cinema deal
like Amazon Prime Time oh I rented it on
Apple TV Apple TV like 15 grid okay it's
not Cinema thing for me okay I'm not
gonna lie I wouldn't go to the cinema is
very intense and wow he acts he'll get
you he'll get your heartstrings where
bro okay he'll get your [__]
heartstrings I'm happy I say proud of
him I'm happy for him I'm super happy
because I know there was a time where
his career was in the pan to be fair
like I said I didn't know he was in the
affair because I don't think I've gotten
that far I think I maybe stopped on
maybe season two
um and obviously we all know him from uh
is it Tarzan or Georgia Georgia
Line those are his two major accolades
for me yeah and that was when we were
kids bro bro with an Oscar this year old
man yeah wow I remember oh I remember
he's in one film called
um
what's it called bro what's that about
it's a it's about
um he's
like getting moved to by like the devil
or something
and the devil is played it's about a
chick by a banging chick yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's banging chick wow
it's called like um
Google it for me please bro bedazzled I
was gonna say for Dazzle but it didn't
sound right yeah what's the chick's name
her name is Elizabeth Hurley Elizabeth
Hurley
yeah brother I remember I remember she's
like 90 years old and she would still
get it till now yeah yeah I [__] I
remember she was dirty how Brendan
Fraser obviously it's a film I remember
watching it it was on Sky movies on
repeat when I was like 13. repeat well
it was on Skype you know Sky movies just
have a film
I want to watch it like nine times yeah
in this didn't and I was thinking
because she was trying to bang Brendan
Fraser in this movie how was he not done
how was he not banging the devil the
devil would take my soul yeah if it was
Elizabeth Hurley yeah wow
um she's also
Google Elizabeth Hurley's son I'm not
gonna lie to you she's got some gay son
right okay
on a drunken one son Elizabeth early son
I know I'm not gonna lie to you on a
very very drunken one oh they look alike
the sun looks like the mum
so I'm telling you on a dog
the sun is a pretty little Tom pretty
little things he's a pretty little Psalm
the sun looks like the [__] mother
they look alive
I'm telling you I'm telling you bro that
I could move to you on a wet lip sting
and you've had a couple couple songs
might just tell you have you ever
watched bedazzled
I would want to wear this conversation
it'll slap you up I'm telling you if
you've got a like Fam I'm telling you
straight now I'm a I'm a straight man as
an arrow as as an arrow my guy yeah yeah
if Elizabeth Hurley's son hit me on a
drunk one and I haven't fapped or banged
in like three weeks yeah and man just
said have you ever seen bedazzled
because he's got lips on him
Google this as well you need to see this
brother he's got a pair of lips on him
and a pair of lips and a pair of eyes
this guy's mom's eyes
this dude will suck the skin off you
that is hilarious yeah let me see Ellis
clock him and see look a life is
unbelievable look his face yeah they do
kidnap the thumb
he's got he's got a jaw on him
unfortunately unfortunately yeah but
found they look alive yeah he's a little
yeah
wow wow
wow now his mom is a thing
his mom is a team facts wow he didn't
play yeah look at this look at this hair
yeah he's sucking you off him
he's I'm telling you now you're doing it
yeah that doesn't make that hair is it
doesn't make sense to me that hair
doesn't make sense to me he's so
luscious it is bro it's so luscious
wow that's a thing
that's the team that picture what has to
take Santa's address put it on the
episode that's a team
luscious wow Luscious Hair lashes lips
his eyes Damien honey Damien Hurley yeah
yeah that's the literally the son of the
devil true literally 666. that's the
sound of the devil yeah wow wow wow yeah
bedazzled brawl that was my first I was
like 12 13. wow and I remember thinking
how Brendan Fraser's not banging this
woman is not making sense to me she's
unbelievable Jesus Christ anyway get
back to it
um that was a funny segue yeah
the whale movie yeah I'm gonna watch it
I'm gonna say you'll when you watch it
you'll realize the last five seconds of
the movie
the worst thing you've seen
just the last five seconds
oh it's stupid I don't even know what
they've ruined it just the last five
seconds but
really really good movie
um speaking of the Oscars everything
everywhere all at once have you seen
that movie yeah yeah it won everything
it did yeah not gonna lie
Jamie Lee Curtis did not deserve an
Oscar for best support God no she didn't
did not make sure about that I forgot
about that yeah are you mad what was she
in that movie again she was some
accountant yeah some IRS thing oh yeah
it didn't make sense that she was best
supporting actress oh yeah I was
surprised when I saw him come home with
that I was like I mean you've been in
the game a minute yeah yeah yeah but
still yeah she was just doing up sausage
fingers in that movie yeah that's all
she did I forgot couldn't believe it
best support Oscar yeah no I'm sorry
your resume doesn't deserve that good
movie though strong yeah strong movie
strong movie a lot to digest yeah
I don't remember
um elliswood like this have you seen the
movie everything everywhere all at once
I haven't known it's a good movie it's
complex Multiverse thing and apparently
the editor
um for it he won Oscar for best editor I
believe no editor
[Laughter]
and apparently he edited the whole film
on like Premiere Pro
he posted on his Instagram
um what his timeline looked like for the
film hmm bro it's Just Dance
everywhere
and when you watch the movie there's
when you watch it because the editing's
complex in this movie because remember
when they're doing like the yeah through
the dimensions oh yeah yeah it is when
you watch it you'll be like this is an
editor what's it on
um Amazon yeah yeah
um yeah yeah yeah it's good bro yeah um
but yeah anyway the Well's good Brendan
phrase I'm gasped for him
um but yeah I have a question for you
yeah yeah so have you seen this
um
this Fredo thing that's going around oh
him so I've not I've seen it but I've
not dived into the context of it so
Random Yeah so basically give the
context so the concept was there's this
like um I can find it actually
there's like this plus size model thing
she went on no jumper with Adam 22 this
thing yeah yeah yeah and then he was
talking to her because I think she does
um only fans as well okay and um he was
Adam no it wasn't Adam he wasn't without
she wasn't with Adam she was on no
jumper but she wasn't bad I'm sorry
um but yeah so the model she's chatting
chatting chatting and then the guy asked
her oh is anyone like famous ever moved
to you and she was like yeah
um I'm really pissed off because I was
down and I bottled it because like I
posted him on my Instagram and like
um he was moving to me like oh I saw you
in this I saw you on this video like I
think you're paying let me fly you out
to Greece
um stay in some 15 bags a night Hotel
kind of thing like that and um the guy
who was like oh swear like who was it
and then she was like oh Fredo from the
UK and um the guy was like swear she was
like yeah yeah he said he hadn't even
heard of him I remember yeah yeah he was
like I don't know who that is and she
was like yeah it's massive in the UK etc
etc
um the comments were
[Music]
a man responded and said
I don't know how to drive a lorry yeah
I've never driven a lorry in my life I
was what a response
I said I've never driven a bus I've
never driven a lorry I was like what's a
response yeah so my question for you
yeah was if you were just going because
he's denying the whole thing yeah
obviously yeah it's big girl yeah not
gonna lie to it I'm sure she's lovely
big girl
if you were minding your business and
then you saw
you saw some big only fans thing with
tattoos on her face in America or no
jumper saying yeah yeah yeah I got moved
to
um and was and the guy was like who is
it who is it and she was like oh if you
heard from the UK
what and I've categorically done nothing
you've never seen this girl before oh
just it will be easy for me because I'll
be angry at first yeah I'd have to the
thing with me because I'm deep in it now
I would have to let the anger subside
before I reply because if I reply
angrily it's gonna obviously seem as if
I'm a liar yeah yeah yeah [__] so I have
to play it cool yeah so I'll let the
Angus I'll Bell you yeah straight oh I
would answer immediately I'll go
straight away yeah what the [__] what
the [__] blah blah blah well let the
anger subside and then I will literally
say I'll probably go on live or some and
just say just show the receipts if I'm
the one that was there yeah you'll be
able to show the receipts fast because I
I know I've not done this will be that
simple bro I wouldn't get into a hoo-ha
about it but that this is the thing as
well was like obviously she's not going
to show you the receipts yeah but like
the seeds out there now yeah yeah
because even with the freddo thing like
obviously she's not showing her receipts
but like it's people are just like
and that's the thing as well is because
you'd be such a random person for to say
it sounds like it has to be true yeah
facts because for her to say if you're
from the UK I would literally be like
swear swear yeah yeah yeah Fair because
it's so it's so specific yeah
um yeah mad I would have to even if she
doesn't show the receipts I'll just be
like flower I've never met this girl
like it I probably wouldn't sweat as
much as I think I will swear all right
so what I mean yeah because I know my
innocence at the time if I know I'm
innocent there's just no need for me to
go above and beyond yeah yeah that's
just the truth facts that's literally
just the truth Bobby I would say if I'm
the one that moved to you show the
receipts if you can't show the receipts
then this conversation's over it'll be
that simple come on it'll be that simple
I'll live it yeah you get me wrong I'll
be living spam but yeah because I know
that will do the rounds bro your DMs
would be you you wouldn't be able to
open a DM and not see this girl's face
for the next week or two bro that will
do the wrong ah I would hate that for
you I would literally hate that for you
and the thing is all you don't have a
leg to stand on yeah because as soon as
they're like
but why would she say you yeah and then
your only answer is I don't know
if she was lying she would have said
someone bigger than you yep
sure she would have said someone bigger
than you why would she lie true me
specifically yeah and I say no so it
does something the whole thing is sucks
I'll one million percent be living yeah
I'll be one million percent what would
you do what would I do would you handle
it if same thing same sorry
um
oh oh
um my uncle get the best of me yeah okay
I would build a meeting obviously I'll
build you immediately yeah yeah and I
know you'll be laughing as soon as I
answer I don't make me want to love my
phone
my [__] phone
number whose team are you on yeah yeah
yeah you see him you're actually almost
laughing
and then you I know you you're asking
the question and now I mean is it true
if I you know I have to ask you is it
true tell me I'll be like tell me what
happened just tell me what happened we
worked through it man to manage I need
to know all this information because I
need to back you in this yeah
I just say just tell me
we can't come to the studio on Thursday
you can't look at people we can't play
tables facts bro I'd want to fight yeah
I know I don't know I'd hate the whole
thing oh so would I so would I though my
thing would never my thing would never
be as smooth as I've never driven a
lorry I'll be on the story shaking yeah
and I'll be stuttering and the more I
started he actually did it it was him
yeah it was him no wonder we started it
was him he started look you can't do a
cohesive cohesive sentence
yeah trying to think of lies on a spot
yeah that's what they were saying oh I
wouldn't be able to deal with it yeah
it's long I would hate them I would hate
that I said I've never driven a lorry
wow yeah
off the cough man said I like him
European
I was like wow
all right
um let's do a dilemma to finish this one
okay let's go all right so I've got
another [__] it's not um yeah a
thingy right so am I the [__] so for
about two years me and this boy have
been on and off but whenever we're off
is because I've cut him off he's the
best I've ever had in terms of sexual
experiences and is so good looking it's
mad okay anyways I stopped talking to
him in July but we'd been flirting
afterwards anyway
comes to find out in January
he just asked this girl to be his
girlfriend ever since then I've been
heartbroken and I won him back so bad of
course you do trust me bro
we have mutual friends
and so I found out stuff like his sexual
experiences with her are [__] and he
doesn't even like her that much
okay fam
while they've been together
um we've been to each other's houses and
even though nothing's happened the
tension is unbelievable expected facts
will I be the [__] for telling him
how I feel
um and getting him back
okay give me a so give me a summary
complete summary she's been on and off
with this girl with this guy for two
years yeah
every time he's at office because she
cuts him off yeah he's now got himself a
new thing yep and she's like raw yep I
need him back yep
she's heard through the grapevine that
he doesn't actually like his girlfriend
that much and their sex is dead yeah so
she's thinking gang
can I met would I be the [__] if I
message him and get him back and they
they've been to each other's yards
frequently she said they've been to each
other's yards whilst he's been in this
relationship and attention and the
tension's up nothing's happened but the
tension's up which should be an [__]
for expressing their feet as they're
trying to get him back yeah yeah she
will be facts without that's open and
shut without a shadow of a doubt because
if the roles were reversed you would say
he's the [__] 100 one million every
guy wants every girl will say oh he's a
[__] [__] yeah yeah those were
reversed exactly that
um and she's not got a leg to stand on
as well because every time they're off
quote unquote she's locked it off so
yeah bro you don't want him you don't
want him but you you she does want him
she wants what she wants she wants him
to want her more than she wants him
and she wants
she wants to be the one that he's asking
not be my girlfriend kind of thing she
wants to be that she's seeing that he's
doing that to next girl and I was like
Wow even if she doesn't say yes yeah to
ask me facts why is he asking next girl
to be his girlfriend because she already
done said he's fit as [__] yo yeah she
said that the sex is unreal and he's
banging
so why are you locking him off what's
what's what's his power play are you are
you happy with what you had she likes
that I did I think yeah she likes the
idea of him yeah in this so yeah you
can't be cutting people off and as soon
as he moved on she was like wow wow okay
yeah come back come back come back come
back come back he's always he always
um don't know what you have until it's
gone type of thing that's that's just
life but um yeah it's open and shut you
definitely will be the [__] if you
express how you feel and try and act on
it
um
it's also tough because
what's the point of them going into each
other's yards and tension is up and then
just before I don't understand that any
of that dynamic because that's pointless
it's all pointless and also first of all
big ego to be like am I the [__] to
get if I get him back she said with
confidence yeah man said I know he'll
leave his girl for me I know he will
that's massive ego massive ego there and
um for two
also don't necessarily don't be out here
believing just because you heard through
the grapevine are there sex is dead
don't start just believe in Grapevine
stuff I have not said that sex with my
girl yeah so what are you hearing who
are you hearing it from who are you
hearing it from yeah
who is said Grapevine literally who's
who's Grapevine because I never said
that I didn't say that I love her
girlfriend that's my [__] girlfriend
what are we talking about here don't
speak about me I'm just speak about her
facts keep her name out of your mouth
yeah
facts bro that's another thing as well
like even if all of that was true yeah
no girl could ever come back to me and
be like oh I heard the Sexes of your
girl is dead when you come see me I
would get defensive spots my sex with my
girl is what yeah on the [__] who even
are you bro bro your Butters yeah that's
why I'm with her not with you I would
lose my mind in fact
trash
but don't ever think about my guy like
that [__] don't ever speak up
oh you probably don't know but um like
when you're growing up and you've got a
younger sibling okay you hate your
brother you hate them but no one else is
going to talk to Mike about that
yes no one's talking about my goal like
that yeah you've lost your [__] mind
my sex and my gut is dead actually who
actually are you so yeah you are the
[__] open and sharp yeah it's it's
done but yeah it's just an ego thing for
yourself clearly yeah because once
you've got him you're not going to be
satisfied facts you're just gonna do
exactly what you've done last year or
for the past two years get bored or
whatever lock him off and then it's the
same cycle again facts
um but yeah anyway that was a short and
sweet one today guys
um Come and catch us on Thursday
um and yeah man it's just Vibes all
around thank you very much for wasting
your time with us
[Music]
foreign